Denise and Brian the man we spoke with
tonight says he reached out after he saw
our story last week on Dwayne's
Automotive he's now one of several who
says they can't get their car or their
money back
as you can see my truck is still sitting
there Gino darling hasn't had his truck
for months it's extremely frustrating
and you know financially frustrating he
says he dropped it here at Duane's
Automotive in May to get a new
transmission paid 3 900 and has been
trying to get it back ever since the
excuses went from mechanical you know
couldn't get the transmission wrong gas
tank he shared what he says are dozens
of text messages with the owner
promising to return it repaired until
eventually but after July 4th he started
becoming a ghost and unfortunately Gino
isn't alone he's one of several who
reached out to eight news now after our
story on Dwayne's aired last week it was
parked right either on that list Aaron
schlifkop told us he hasn't seen his car
in a year after paying five thousand
dollars we are unable to
call it this time this time since the
main number says it's out of service we
reached out to the Nevada DMV compliance
enforcement division they say both Geno
and Aaron's claims are being
investigated it was my grandfather's
track and so it even means a lot more to
me than just a you know a car Gino tells
us at this point he doesn't care if the
work is completed he just wants what
belongs to him and he won't give up
until he has it again Carl just give me
my truck back
and the Nevada compliance enforcement
rather says that they do handle cases
like this they encourage anyone else
having an issue to reach out to them we
also reached out to the Attorney
General's office they say they have not
received any complaints both men do tell
me though that they did file incident
reports as well with Henderson police
reporting live in Henderson tonight
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now